[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show a
couple of stories i think you'll find
interesting then i'll tell you something
that took place over the weekend related
to a passover seder that i went to so
michael avenatti this lawyer who became
known in political circles for
representing stormy Daniels actually I
can take my headphones off don't even
know why I'm wearing them right now
Michael avenatti has been accused of
embezzling 1.5 million dollars from an
NBA player named Hassan Whiteside
according to a report this is being
reported by the Los Angeles Times and
but bank records and an indictment
brought against avenatti claim that in
2017 Whiteside who plays for the Miami
Heat
wired almost three million dollars to
Michael avenatti which was intended for
his former girlfriend alexis gardener
and the idea was she would get most of
the money and avenatti was entitled to
slightly more than a million dollars in
fees as part of this deal according to
the LA Times but prosecutors say that
avenatti had hid the full amount of
money from Gardner took 2.5 million
dollars put it towards a private jet and
as you can imagine off we go with yet
another Michael avenatti scandal so I
think that mitt we've learned maybe a
couple of things from the constant now
scandals invite involving Michael
avenatti um our instinct from the
beginning that this was not a great
character for the progressive movement
and not someone that the left should be
even remotely thinking about maybe he
should run for president in 2020 as I
told you from the very beginning to the
extent that stormy Daniels is getting
good representation from him and we
could debate whether he she was or
wasn't okay to the extent that this guy
can reveal actual wrongdoing by people
in in positions of power we welcome it
but he's always struck most people who
have sort of a sense of other people's
behavior as not someone that is a on the
up-and-up in total and every single one
of these news stories about him have
confirmed that and you know the the
problem is it's sort of like who really
cares except that by giving him so much
airtime as many corporate media channels
did and by allowing him to be presented
as a guy in a position of authority
knowledge power and and sort of right
acting the they are now opened up to
significant criticism from the right and
if you look on right-wing Twitter at all
you will see that they are just all over
Michael avenatti in a way that's not
particularly good for the left
so another despicable allegation against
Michael avenatti we've been saying from
the beginning on this show that this is
not a guy we should be investing in in
terms of being any kind of significant
player in the future of progressive
American politics and now that's
abundantly clear the upside is because
it's so clear I don't think we're gonna
have to have an argument anymore about
whether Michael avenatti should be a
primary or important participant in the
progressive movement I think at this
point basically everybody on the Left no
one I can think of on the left is still
saying that this is a guy we want
involved with what they're doing this is
kind of a funny story I feel kind of bad
for my mom about this but it's also just
funny and I don't think she was really
trying to do anything wrong I mentioned
this on a live stream last week stop and
shop which is a supermarket chain in the
northeast of the United States I don't
know how far they extend employees have
been striking for weeks I believe dating
back to April 11th okay so eleven days
about a week and a half almost two weeks
and they're striking over pay their try
striking over health benefits and it has
been really in the news a lot of
prominent politicians expressing their
support in solidarity with the striking
stop and shop workers I don't really go
to stop and shop but sometimes I go to
stop and shop for gasoline I've not been
going just being aware
what has been going on and it's really
been like a major major news story we
learned this morning that it appears as
though they are very close to reaching
an agreement which will get employees
back to work and it'll get the stores
reopened and that's all you know
hopefully it gets resolved in a way that
is actually good for workers but there's
a couple funny stories that are going
along with it I'll tell you the one
about my mom in a second one is that
there's another supermarket chain in the
area called Big Y which as far as I know
and like former producer Louis worked
there when we were in high school at big
Y and many other people I know have
worked there over time as far as I know
they're extraordinarily anti-union so
anti-union that they have actually
successfully suppressed unions for
decades at big Y so you have this kind
of like a cute union related thing going
on it's stop and shop and a lot of
people are saying rightly I'm not going
to cross the picket line and then they
go to Big Y which has is it's so
anti-union that there's just not even a
chance that any kind of union would
develop at big why what's the right
thing to do I don't actually know I
don't know the answer I know that
crossing the picket line when there are
striking workers is not good but then to
say well I'm gonna go and give money to
the place that has succeeded in
suppressing unions for decades that also
doesn't really feel like the right thing
so what what I've been doing is just
continuing to try to go to local grocery
stores to the extent that they exist
aside from the stop and shop strike and
I do sometimes go to Whole Foods which
was against Obamacare now Whole Foods is
owned by Amazon what you know I don't
know I I feel like it's a very difficult
situation for consumers particularly
when a lot of the local grocery stores
where I live are quite frankly not good
but the situation involving my mom is
she somehow didn't really know what was
going on and she told me last week that
she went to a stop and shop and saw that
it was mostly empty and that there were
tons of employees outside she didn't
really know what was going on and she
just went in and did her shopping and
then only later learned what was going
on and I said mom you crossed the picket
line and you support unions and you
support workers and she felt really
really bad and said she would go to Big
Y instead at which
I explained to her you know big big y is
really anti-union
and they have been successfully so for
for a very long time so I don't know
tell me what you think what is the right
thing to do in these cases you know and
at a certain point it becomes an a
common example is you don't want to help
the the oil industry by having a car and
purchasing gasoline but at the same time
you need the car to do your activism to
mitigate the effects of climate change
how do you weigh it is your activism
worth the patronizing of oil companies
and burning of fossil fuels because
you're trying to fix the problems we're
creating with fossil fuels how does
anyone make that calculation I genuinely
don't know and that applies to this show
as well right we have a carbon footprint
I travel to conferences where I
interview newsmakers that as a carbon
footprint should I just sit in a room in
the dark to not use lights and
electricity what's the level to which
each of us is comfortable saying this is
a valuable exchange based on what we're
getting out of it I don't know if
there's any simple answers to it but I'm
curious to hear from you if you follow
me on instagram at david pakman you
might have seen that i posted a picture
wearing a yarmulke on saturday from a
passover seder drinking wine not
Manischewitz
better wine i will make very clear I
went to a Passover Seder as I do most
years and a lot of people very angrily
saying David how can you do this I
thought you were an atheist I thought
you were agnostic and you're wearing a
yarmulke and attending a seder which is
a religious event it's your traitorous
and blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
and not that I was starting to argue
with people on Instagram but a bunch of
my friends wrote to me and they said I
saw what you posted and I saw all these
angry people don't they understand
cultural Judaism and the answer is a lot
of people don't I mean in the same way
that a lot of people do presents around
Christmas or I don't know do an Easter
egg hunt around
Easter without literally believing that
Jesus Christ had been resurrected at
that point in time for the sort of
family and community and traditional
reasons with Judaism I don't remember
what percentage but I think it's like
75% of Jews or something like that
consider themselves Jewish but secular
in the sense that they are part of the
Jewish culture many of them are
ethnically Jewish Jewish yes that's a
thing you can look it up and check out
my DNA test without literally believing
that God was choosing which houses to
pass over based on whether they had been
painted with I don't remember even if it
was supposedly blood or whatever knowing
not to kill the firstborn of the people
within those homes I don't believe any
of that stuff as people know but I
identify culturally as Jewish I do very
very little I mean Hanukkah I might
light candles one or two of the nights
if I'm home and my girlfriend remembers
but Passover is actually one that I do
enjoy getting to see people I don't see
most of the year and having some of the
foods and the hérault sit with the matzo
and the entire thing so please don't be
angry with me for participating in what
for me is a cultural thing I don't have
the religious beliefs
some people do and I'm glad to debate
with them the truth or falsity of those
religious beliefs and whether they are
backed by science or history and I
believe that they are not but I actually
had one person right and said say that
they were cancelling their membership
because they can't support in good faith
anyone who follows religious dogma it
could have been one of these
unsubscribed trolls who's not even
actually a member
although I don't know their Instagram
username did not indicate to me their
real name therefore I couldn't actually
look up whether they were or were not a
member but come on come on cultural
people celebrate Christmas without
believing the Christian Jesus story
people celebrate Easter people celebrate
all sorts of stuff and I had a lovely
Passover by the way I will say matzo
ball soup fantastic some of the other
food you know so so so but overall
a great-great Passover and thanks to
everybody who actually said hope you had
a nice time David and didn't drink too
much wine which I didn't I really don't
I I don't I don't drink a lot ever so
just add a little bit of red wine that
does it for me I am out of town as many
of you can see and notice the remote
setup continues to improve I actually
have people who write to me and they say
David when your remote the lighting is
almost better because I have very nice
front lighting the background is further
in the distance which creates more
separation between me in the background
I have people who say they love the
lighting when I'm remote
although the audio sometimes people
don't like as much it is an inferior
microphone I have an sm58 that I bring
with me which is like a I think it's
like a hundred and twenty dollar
microphone very popular mic for voice
but it is not an e V re 20 which is what
we have in the studio and it is a much
more expensive microphone so I guess the
Lighting's good the sound may be not
quite as good or at least different but
I'm continuing to work on it and
tomorrow should be even better
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]